alexander Schultz teeters along a 610
meter long slackline in a desert in
northern China he's got to reach the end
by sundown he's already had to break off
five attempts after nearly an hour of
intense concentration he's made it it's
the fourth world record for Alexandra
Schultz in a single year in me I'm
Allison everyone had pretty much given
up on me because the Sun was about to go
down and I was exhausted from the heat
in the previous attempts then
fortunately I made it we're all thrilled
alabanza [ __ ] Floyd nine in the morning
near Innsbruck Austria 24 year old
Alexandra Schultz gets together with his
team regularly to practice for new
record attempts this time it's not about
the length of the line it's the height
the slack line stretches for 40 meters
between two cliffs this sub-discipline
is known as highlining bum highland
that's the High Line the challenge is
the height you can feel it and that
makes it harder than being close to the
ground the primal fear of being
vulnerable takes hold you can feel the
edge of the abyss and on the high line
the feeling is more intense when she'd
on duska few days after hellenic feel
intense Eva yangshuo China in November
2014
this lack line is 100 meters high and
375 meters long a distance alexander
schultz hadn't even attempted close to
the ground he struggled with it and with
himself for four days and set a new
world highline record but the triumph
didn't last just months later a new
record was set 403 meters with every
additional meter a slackline is harder
to walk harder to control [ __ ] is this
the wobbling is what throws you off a
slackline so the biggest challenge is
compensating for the wobbling and that's
a lot harder when you're highlighting
because you have to deal with the mental
aspect everything inside you is saying
you don't even want to be here that
makes you afraid and when it starts
wobbling you're afraid of falling
Johannes olszewski the team's video
cameraman and photographer chronicles
every slackline effort the world record
attempts like this one at Lake IPA last
August
and the spectacular feats like the
crossing of the Great Wall of China or a
walk between two cable car gondolas on
Germany's highest mountain that suks
pizza the team are all dedicated slack
liners and they keep coming up with new
ideas but the longest lines are reserved
for Alexandra Schultz as soon as you
think about reaching the end you fail
usually just moments or seconds later
and this is what I admire most about
Alex as soon as he's on the slackline
his movements are dynamic and fluid and
he's firmly rooted in the moment
Alexandra Schultz has to work
intensively to get in shape to tackle
World Records doing yoga sharpens his
ability to navigate ever longer and
wobbly r slacklines
hello Bassam
one great ambition for him and his team
is to walk a slackline one kilometer
long a few years ago that would have
been unthinkable but now Alexander
Schultz feels ready for the challenge he
might well go for it sometime this year
tells me that I'm borden beside the
major difficulty was walking a thousand
meters close to the ground as finding a
suitable spot with the necessary
vertical profile on flat ground you'd
start much too high and unsecured it but
now I'm sure it's going to work out it's
just a matter of finding the perfect
spot
aside from the record attempts more
spectacular happenings are in the
planning such as slacklining over an
active volcano alexander schultz has no
trouble pushing the envelope farther on
down the line